I also still like to think about like
what's the next most controversial thing
he can do yeah because once you're
anti-semitic what's past that or what if
he uh
cuts off his dick and then puts it back
on and then he goes what am I now
[Music]
uh Kanye has been kicked off of Twitter
oh [ __ ] you talk about yay yeah I
thought Elon was trying to keep
everybody on I think this one was too
wild what'd he say this time so he kind
of wild it out a little bit and then um
a little more than yours he posted a
picture that appeared to be a not a
Nancy swastika inside the Star of David
and indicated that it would be used as
the logo for his presidential campaign
and he's like it's a mashup
he's the Double Down King this
[ __ ] is crazy wait wait why wait
I gotta see it from his side is there is
there a devil's advocate way of of
pitching a star of David with the swamps
trying to bring peace
oh as soon as I said that I regret it so
I think he's Devil's advocating no I'm
just kidding I have no idea what he's
doing uh what's the purpose no because
he just went on the whole thing
yesterday when he went on Alex Jones uh
Alex Jones's show and was saying that
like Hitler is kind of tight he looks
kind of chill and I'm all for it yeah
but he was also on the show with a full
[ __ ] match and then like Alex Jones
yeah he's like he kept trying to give
him like little else and he's like nah
man I think he was done he's like have
you heard about my lawsuit he said let
me tell you he's like let me just clear
all this what's going on up
the best things about Hitler top five
okay
real smart sick painter was this was
this really how he was saying it yeah no
Alex Jones was like he's like no well
the Nazis did a lot of horrible things
and then um Connie's like not everything
he's like they're just some nah man
really yeah it was like
it's not like verbatim but he kept
trying to tell him like I like Alex
Jones said I don't personally like
Hitler I don't personally like him
and then Kanye responded how like that
like he was literally but Hitler has a
couple of good things right like called
the Volkswagen Volkswagen he doesn't hit
singles yeah but his uh discography is
kind of you know yeah it's a little all
over it's so funny because they act like
he's the one that was sitting there
drawing and [ __ ] making the beetle
that is the funniest thing about it it's
like he didn't do anything right he just
just deployed the people exactly or
funded it somehow yeah right like he's
the one [ __ ] he just did the clay
model yeah that's like saying that he he
lit the reichstag fire like he's in
there with a [ __ ] gas tank he's not
doing all that he was chilling up at the
top bro yeah he was kicking it what was
his wife's name Ava Brown yeah LeBron
yeah he was kicking with everyone
apparently that food just [ __ ] went
out into his castle and just banged her
all day and started writing poetry and
[ __ ] and doing math or speed or whatever
yeah and painting German Shepherds dude
come on wait do you happen to have this
photo of said swastika inside I'm not
putting it up they'll put it up like
low-key like I could imagine it and yet
I can't because I've never check it out
I'll show you after hey did we talk
about where phones do you get flagged by
the yeah did we talk about that uh video
clip that came out I don't know if it
was recent or if it just like kind of
resurfaced but it was uh Hitler at the
Olympics and he's watching
and he's just like he's like messed out
dude just like tripping you it's a crazy
video wow okay obviously it's a terrible
idea but as a design concept and how it
connects I'm like oh that's not bad so
you would wear that
so you'd wear it I just don't is that
part of the kinesthetic I don't like how
the Nazis took the swastikos they did
take it from that's some [ __ ] it's
weird my favorite part of the logo is
the star I know I feel bad for Buddhist
that like a good part of it yeah because
there was a little girl that got well
she was little I think she was like a
college student but you know how
sometimes you get something from the
temple and it's got the swastika yes she
was getting lectured and there was this
whole controversy because this [ __ ]
old [ __ ] was like stinker without even
understanding the context behind it do
you think Kanye's like gets a guy on
Fiverr and he's like so I'm thinking
like you take the swastika
PewDiePie all right so now as as JK we
have to figure out what is his next move
is gonna be and what his next point is
going to be I don't know so he doubled
down like I think two years ago so now
he's at like [ __ ] what quadruple down
until yeah yeah it seems like he really
goes home
and with his creative genius it's like
what is the most controversial how can I
get even more controversial you know
what I mean whether it be like wearing a
white lives matter t-shirt you know what
I mean to dude White lives matter
compared to this is like that's nothing
now yeah yeah it's nothing but that's
what I'm saying it's like is he just
constantly like what is it more
controversy she's thinking about the
wrong Parts like he's not thinking about
the dunk he's thinking about the
alley-oops and the each alley you just
gets [ __ ] crazier and they're like
okay so how do you finish that and it
just doesn't it's just more crazy alley
so it's a Harlem Globetrotters but they
haven't finished
he's he's the guys on YouTube that do
like the trick shots where they they
take five balls and they tape it all
together and they try to throw it in the
hoop and they're like that's crazy
setups but then you're like okay is
there a genius like clothes but there
isn't he's the Turkish ice cream vendor
that just keeps taking it like doing
this and you're just like come on man I
just want ice cream it's bad for
business it's literally stop doing Nazi
[ __ ] give me the ice cream he's a Mark
he's a mark Rober video but he doesn't
he doesn't stick The Landing yeah
because I I I wished there was like some
crazy dope lesson that came you know and
everyone's like ah I get it but there is
no I get it from like the last three
things I think he's just really manic
too like this dude is just like uh he's
yeah he's he's his wheels are spinning
and there's just nothing to get from the
only thing he can do now is just hire a
documentary film crew and just act like
he was like [ __ ] LARPing this whole
time yeah yeah yeah that's the only
thing that's the only way out yeah or he
drops like the hottest album ever bro oh
it's called the Third Reich if he drops
it's like the first album to go I don't
know like triple diamond or something
yeah it's like a river Phoenix Texas
everybody has to like talk about it like
hey like okay I know Kanye's been
Wildland but I know this album's called
mine comp but you've got three bro it's
so good you got baby keema there he got
baby came on he's going car dude yeah
Kendrick on track too crazy like if he
does that
then it's like oh but but I don't I
don't think he will I don't think I
don't think he's making music anymore if
he does he's gonna make more homeless
clothes I just saw that him and uh Kim's
divorce got settled and he's got to pay
like 200 G's a month in child support or
something too Jesus Christ that's a grip
for if Chase or whatever is stopping his
payments and Adidas pulled the plug you
got like 10 kids he got like four kids
huh dude if he doesn't pay a lot for
someone at his level a month what if
everyone has choke holds on his finances
Oh you mean like oh like if it's
freezing his asset because
[Laughter]
yeah Chase is froze his account really
Adidas pulled the plug on him so he like
if he films
why did they do that if he films the sex
tape we can't just Owens at the
Holocaust Museum yeah and Pete Davis oh
my God I think he raises that money
quick that's true and then starter only
fans dude Anthony and it's in black and
white
he's like what
what they froze froze counts like like a
Russian oligarch no I don't think they
froze it I think they said that they
don't uh they gave him a specific amount
of time to move his account his money uh
because they don't want it because they
don't want to serve him yeah they're
denying him sir a bank doesn't want to
[ __ ] with his money that's crazy so he
really angry back to others say like
what if he [ __ ] Pete Davidson dude oh
that'd be crazy like have sex yeah like
he dates Pete Davidson next yeah that's
how he comes back that's how he comes
out Kanye Davidson have sex yeah
everybody's minds are blown yeah that's
another crazy alley-oop with I don't
know what the dunk is I don't know what
the lesson what's the lesson in this
Bart's like what's that the lesson is
that Pete Davidson ran through all the
hottest women and now he's going to the
hottest dude
Ryan Gosling yeah he's like what more
could I get he's like come on I gotta
prove it the other way now I get anybody
I am deserving of love I think that
there should be a Kanye biopic that
comes out with the John David Washington
played him that who's John David
Washington Denzel's son he actually kind
of looks like it yeah he actually kind
of looked like him right he can mimic
him I think that's what I'm saying wow I
think Johnny Sins should play him
at the doctor you want to see something
really Go the Distance
I also still like to think about like
what's the next most controversial thing
he can do yeah that's that's what that's
the only way we tapped out I'm tapped
out like him and Kenneth's own sucks
because once you're anti-semitic what's
past that in the western world not much
he's also really creative I feel like he
could probably outdo himself another
five more times yeah he's probably like
this ain't nothing dude I didn't think
he would do this he's looking at the
Balenciaga like a baby BDSM stuff and
he's like that's good that's good I
[ __ ] up by by not messing with those
guys anymore yeah because did they drop
him or something like that did they like
kind of say [ __ ] you we're out
Balenciaga with him I think Balenciaga
was like Kanye you're while I'm out I
believe you they distance themselves
that was like part of the joke of like
everyone distancing themselves and then
they were like check this out we're
gonna top Yukon yeah we're gonna try to
I think Kim's like I'm distancing myself
because she was like hello rocking
Valencia yeah she like formally like uh
is she ending it in the business with
them or she was it's over now because of
all that anything worse than
anti-semitic in terms of like like
[ __ ] children maybe yeah pedophilia
oh that's true that is worse yeah that
is a little worse so that's why I'm
saying with even with the balenciagara
stuff like he suddenly goes in that
direction because it does or what if he
uh cuts off his dick and then puts it
back on and then he goes what am I now
am I yeah right okay like if he
Transitions and transitions back is that
even more I don't know but in the middle
of the transition he [ __ ] Pete Davidson
what am I now I don't know
crazy let me know I hear you what a
crazy [ __ ] dude dude him
defending Hitler I like how fast this
part was
what am I now
that was just another idea that doesn't
go in the hoop though yeah
I mean South Park already did it yeah
the fish sticks he turns it normal he's
the teacher oh yeah that's right what
happened with the teacher they took the
dick off from Mr Garrison right Mr
Garrison he became a woman and then came
back a man again yeah he was like this
is whack and he went back to be a man Mr
Garrison so that's what we expect of You
Kanye or he lives with ISIS
like [ __ ] living over there look I
obviously in America people look at Isis
as like really terrible but I still feel
like in the hierarchy of what Americans
think is the worst thing ever Hitler is
top of the oh yeah for sure it's just
it's like down here it's still like
considered bad but it's not right it's
not as bad as him we'll be going
backwards I think so he's not doing the
album called mineconf he might do an
album called my clothes Okay the third
right that's what it looks but if it's
banging and he got like if it's like
classic sick Kanye I might play that
secrecy you know I just wouldn't like
that it's called My call yeah that's not
cool what about bin Laden you can do
something he brings it back to life
911 didn't happen dude resurrected he
resurrects bin lines he has the power to
do that
next album all the samples are speeches
of [ __ ] [ __ ] dude like Bin Laden or
Hitler or [ __ ] El Chapo or [ __ ]
just Kubla Khan the craziest
[ __ ] you get that Audio blue
he's like dinosaurs
that would be [ __ ] trip man
[Music]
[Music]